boris est à mort aux délégués cgt alstom
un bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt francesco pensez vous
que ce rachat envisagé par votre groupe
un bien c'est clairement une opération
avant tout financière lorsqu on échange
avec eux la direction lorsqu'on lui
demande quelle est la stratégie
industrielle qui a derrière derrière ça
c'est évident lorsqu'on est leur
demander quelles sont les perspectives
en termes de recherche et développement
en termes d'innovation en termes de
développement des capacités
industrielles il ya un silence absolu
sachant que le ferroviaire on est sur
une vague montante pour les dix vingt
trente années à venir en europe
notamment et en france essentiellement
où il y aura beaucoup d'activités donc
là en fait on se constate c'est juste
que et notre direction ne le dit
clairement c'est qu'en fait il ya une
opportunité qui est donc le fait que
bombardier est en très mauvaise
situation financière
donc il pensa à l'acheter juste pour
être plus gros alors derrière il ya
quand même des des enjeux capitalistique
si je puis si je puis dire qui est
notamment le fait que l'actionnaire le
premier actionnaire actuel d' alstom
veut sortir du capital c'est bouygues
il ne veut plus être actionnaire
d'alstom donc il veut sortir est en fait
le montage qui est fait avec bombardier
et la caisse des dépôts du québec lui
lui permettra de sortir du capital
donc c'est une raison financière c'est
absolument pas une raison industrielle
ce projet on vous dit dans un communiqué
intersyndical que les grandes lignes de
cette opération sont opaques pour
quelles raisons pour quelles raisons
bien comme je voulais 10,1
alors lorsqu'on lorsqu'on va lorsqu'on
échanges avec la direction quelle est
votre stratégie industrielle
derrière ça pas de réponse c'est vide
surtout en fait ce qui est plus ce qui
est réellement
plus embêtant ça va être donc d'une
parce que ce que ce qu'a posée la
direction d'alstom
hier à la commission européenne c'est à
dire donc les la liste des remèdes
donc ce que la direction s'engage à
faire pour ne pas être en position
dominante sur certains marchés à
paraître en monopole sur certains
certaines activités
donc c'est à dire céder quelques
activités et encore plus qui nous ce qui
est encore plus opaque à long terme ce
sont les synergies
c'est à dire on sait très bien quand il
ya deux grands groupes comme ceux là qui
fusionne deux entités qui fusionne
derrière à moyen long terme
il ya des restructurations c'est à dire
des fermetures de sites des fermetures
d'activités
par exemple chez alstom et un bureau
d'études qui fait des tramways chez
bombardier il ya un bureau d'études qui
fait des tramways à long terme
il est évident que les deux ne seront
pas gardés
c'est ce qui s'est déjà passé dans
l'histoire dans le passé lorsque
d'alstom ou bombardier ont acheté des
différentes activités différentes usines
à au bout d'un moment il ya des
restructurations donc là on là où c'est
très opaque
c'est l'ampleur de ces restructurations
un terme aujourd'hui la direction nous
dit qu'il n'y réfléchissent pas ou
qu'ils n'y ont pas réfléchi ce qui est
peut-être encore plus inquiétant mais il
va bien falloir aussi avoir avoir ce
large aux autres et vous êtes inquiet
pour les employés de l'usiné alsacienne
que pourrait céder à ce cas alors j'aime
pas le mot inquiets mais il y a eu il ya
beaucoup de problématiques
lusine de reichshoffen qui avant était l
usine de dietrich ferroviaire que alstom
a acheté il ya 20 ans en fait a été
complètement intégré dans le groupe et
donc depuis des années et même encore
très récemment le pdg monsieur
poupart-lafarge disait la main sur le
coeur on a besoin de tout le monde pour
l'avenir il n'y a pas de problème pour
les sites il ya de la charge qui est
temps en temps il ya un petit creux
d'activité mais il ya de la charge
années à venir on a besoin de tout le
monde et là du jour au lendemain on dit
une activité quand même qu'ils aient
c'est stratégique c'est à dire c'est
celle usine
une des usines qui fait aujourd'hui les
trains régionaux pour la france on dit
en fait on l'a brad pour aller faire
cette opération financière
donc là où je pense poser la question
d'une part c est ce que ceux ci le
dossier tel qu'il est posé actuellement
par eux alstom est ce qui va être
accepté ou pas par les différentes
autorités de concurrence que ce soit à
bruxelles mais aussi au canada en chine
et ainsi de suite et surtout bas si si
vraiment ils vont jusque là dedans ça va
être pour les usines de reichshoffen
quel avenir
il ya un petit creux de charge qui
s'annonçait sur l'année prochaine donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça va
devenir
quel va être le repreneur auquel
salariés vont être gardés dans quelles
perspectives d'activité voilà mais à
voilà donc ça ça va être les choses à
terme mais déjà en fait ce qu'on
constate c'est que le projet île et
industriellement il n'est pas
complètement officiers merci beaucoup à
vous bourrez savoir aux d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes délégué cgt à alsting